[Music]
before we get started
katy i want you to open some of your
gifts okay is this a fucking vibrator
i knew it
i don't have a pussy but this i think
you can
you know look you don't have a pussy
vibrating rechargeable waterproof and
silicone
sold as novelty only what does that mean
oh i don't know it's for your novelty
pussy a little light it's for real life
ditto lovely
so maybe there's a check in here no no
check in there
what's that oh yes and then another
thing for your a demi wand a demi wand i
don't know what to do with that i don't
know how any sex toys work is this just
what is demi i don't know i think you
put it on your you know taint beginner
oh beginner it looks like a something
you would use instead of stimulation i
guess i don't get any sex i don't
understand them
you never use sex toys
i never have and i don't know why i
think it's more because i can't i'm not
taking on another charger do you do you
like i don't want to be lose please do
you jerk off i do i used to more but now
i do not okay because it just is a lot
of who has the time it's a lot of work i
gotta go to imdb and look myself up and
then i gotta you gotta check your
credentials it's like a whole thing you
know what i mean i have to find my demo
reel play it for myself to get in the
mood you don't watch the porn i used to
watch the porn when it was on tumblr do
you remember tumblr i still have it
tumblr's done i thought no it's not done
i still um i use the um
i still use it for porn it's not really
like it's kind of like soft core yeah
that's what i liked about it it always
looked consensual
oh yeah yeah
no it used to be it used to be like
disgusting like you know real like
hardcore as you get but now it's just i
think because like there it's no nudity
or whatever it's just like a little bit
of um
kissy kissy and that's about it i kind
of but i liked it also the tumbler porn
i used to watch was in black and white
first of all black and white i know like
old like fred astaire no that was just
not like charlie chaplin
that would be it was the only way i
could be a hitler mustache without
having to google hitler
if somebody like crashes through a
building
i would watch the three stooges i just
love watching men fall on bananas well
that i mean vulnerability is sexy it was
like out of focus black and white do you
remember that chris isaac's helena cruz
video
wanna fall in love
with you
and she's like wearing full butt panties
and had like some black sand on her and
she was like that was like the perfume
commercial days yes and i remember that
was the sexiest thing i had ever seen
and then so i was kind of into black and
white porn and it would go on a loop on
on tumblr remember it would just be like
yes it was almost like giphy's yes yeah
yeah and so you're not like getting lost
in the like you know um like what's is
that a plate of chicken wings in the
background like i get so easily
distracted
you know or i'll just like get sad if i
see too many tattoos or if something
tells a story in the background like is
that a highlights magazine how old is
she yeah or like when they i actually
i've been uh lately i've been seeing in
um porn that um
like shots of people holding the camera
like we're just so like sloppy
filmmaking and i just scream laughing
it's so funny there is a whole genre of
comedy porn oh so but i don't like that
neither do i if you go to pornhub now
it's like
like a girl will walk in on her
boyfriend like and the girls stuck in
the dryer and they're like wait it's
just like bad comedy and i'm like i feel
like if i was 22 i'd be auditioning for
that and not booking it and i hate this
no no i mean you're you're you're lucky
although i mean no disrespect to porn
people you would you could be a great
porn actress well my last name was
cummings and when i first moved sounds
like a porno name when i first moved to
la when you have nothing on your google
right oh they just assume you do there
was a woman named wendy cummings who was
quite a successful porn star who didn't
not look a bit like me and my mom would
google me and it would be do you mean
wendy coming and oh this porn would come
up and my mom thought i was doing porn
for the first couple years and she
wasn't that
she was like at work honestly yeah she
was kind of like all right i didn't
think that anyone would want to pay to
see you naked she's kind of proud of me
and then i'd comedy you know what kind
of point it was
i think it was kind of just um
good old
good old good old
mugsy cam
what is it the walrus two dicks in the
mouth
you and i first bonded over you
explaining mung diving to me yes and i'm
still riding that thing hard okay so is
that do you think that's been done it's
a it's a cousin of the cleveland steamer
the dolphin no i don't think it has any
relatives and um
i think it's just its own
it has its own um
it's kind of like um
i don't know it's a mythology on all its
own i don't think it has any sexual
cousins or anything i think it's like
it's kind of like free soloing
yeah yeah yeah it's more like rock
climbing skydiving things like that like
extreme sports but you only have like a
two-day window to execute your hobby
well oh i mean you the window i think
the window is the the real wild card
there sure sure because you don't know
how the corpse was embalmed sure if it
wasn't if it was at all if it's i mean
you don't know if it's um there's been a
toxicology report if i may recap that
yeah or would you like to please so um
diving it's i love the urban
dictionary's definition which is like um
when uh
when you and a friend go out to a
graveyard and you dig up a corpse that's
been um
but i think buried for like two days so
you know it's getting juicy
that's the key that's the key it's like
the the the
the uh
it's become bloated and yeah that's when
you know like the two or three day
window is the ju you know the level of
juiciness that you want to get and you
so it's like a team effort you have to
dig up the body um and then affix your
mouth to one of the orifices dealer's
choice and then your friend
stands on a tombstone jumps up onto the
the gut and all that fucking nasty dead
juice flies into your mouth and you got
highest and you get high stock
because what is the would it what are
you inhaling the embalmed juice or
that's the 65 000 question does blood
start to turn into like an
ammonia type thing well i think most
i think most embalming practices do um
they
they just they replace the blood in the
circulatory system with some kind of
something else
like um yeah palm olive or whatever and
then you know
and so i think uh but the i don't even
know if they still use formaldehyde
i think it's sema
oh yeah malt licker
mike's hard lemonade yeah
but uh they need to start using whatever
they're using for lennon's corpse in red
square
because that bitch is looking fierce
fresh and fabulous on display dead as
hell and okay so
who is lennon vladimir lenin was the guy
who is cr you know the start of the uh
the russian revolution the bolshevik you
have russian ancestry no
at all no
gattia does not have any russian
ancestry well
no those cheekbones and that's no
no wait wait wait with those cheekbones
and that mouth well the the mouth was
from laureating
[Laughter]
what is your ancestry
why
um like the the the uh genealogy or the
what do you call that 23andme
it is
uh irish scottish swedish and german
really
that's interesting i thought i just
thought yes because i thought you had
some russian ancestry and i was very
excited to talk to you about how every
russian i know has taught that lived in
russia grew up in russia or has friends
in russia
all fully believe not ironically not
bombastically that there are three other
people that have gotten plastic surgery
to look exactly like vladimir putin and
they all alternate oh mama let me tell
you something that so you want to talk
about the truth in russia
no they're saying there isn't they've
had fake news for the idea that news
could ever be true as well they invented
fake news but imagine getting plastic
surgery to look like someone else i mean
i'm just so curious how they choose them
how the casting went down fucking
kidding me they well first of all people
have no choice correct he's an autocrat
wait wait wait wait wait wait we're
trying to texas we're talking about
russia okay sorry
i'm so sorry i mean they're in i've
talked to um
sort of a generation i guess they're
like my parents age so they were like um
in their 60s now here living in west
hollywood for like probably 30 40 years
yes and um they were like russians run
west hollywood thank god yeah they do
and they're you know they like every a
lot of immigrant communities they kind
of settle and then they all um in one
area and it's fierce and um uh but
they're like there's like they've always
known two truths like the truth and then
the real truth right and then i think
that there's just layers and layers of
it now that you don't even it's it's
just like
oh god it's just like this really
exhausting level of skepticism that is i
think hard on the soul
let me ask you about um what's going on
currently as i'm thinking about all that
uh with fentanyl
oh what go ahead somebody asked me for
fentanyl the other day on the street in
london just based on your vibe i guess
so i was i was nodding off naked in the
sidewalk no but i was outside smoking a
cigarette like he asked me for a
cigarette and then he paused he was like
how many times you know i was like what
he's like never mind
okay so i i have so many questions
because i i remember one time i listened
to a uh a podcast you did with rupaul
and you were talking about past days of
of living yeah
living la vida i have never done i know
this is going to come as a shock to
everyone based on my personality and
every choice i've ever made but i have
never done cocaine and i have never done
molly
i know and today's the day
honey because it's odd yeah
and so i was reading about how uh now in
l.a uh the the er just issued a warning
uh that cedar sinai saying that all the
mali in la is now laced with fentanyl
and everyone i know this is their
response they go oh well you can test
for it now you can go buy a test and you
can just test your mole or your cocaine
before you take it am i wrong in
thinking that that cocaine's and it's a
now thing it's not like a hold on guys
let's test it first and wait and if it's
if it's positive are you really not
going to do it are you insinuating that
drug users might be impulsive impatient
and a little bit reckless
well they're serious
um that's a great point and i mean
listen i i don't understand what that is
i think i was there's a there's actually
um this cool strange um
group of people in canada i think who
are they're basically getting drugs
buying large quantities of drugs testing
them and then distributing them or
selling them for free or selling them
for cheap or like on the street to
addicts but they're saying they're
testing it for fentanyl they're testing
it for everything so like here is uh a
pure half gram of methamphetamine pure
but it also has meth in it no no it's
methamphetamine but that's it
right i mean but it's funny the idea
that but it doesn't have anything else
but just but here's the thing when you
go to the hospital and they shoot you
full of ativan they know exactly the
dosage right and it's going they know
exactly what it is it's pure it's
laboratory made and whatever all these
it's not like we're going to give you a
downer just see what happens you know
what i mean like that's so you're not
you know what you're getting and there's
the the harm reduction is like um
just is is uh
it gets to a level that is not
achievable on the street with black
market drugs sure i'm just
what does fentanyl make you feel like
mary i don't know i mean i don't know i
don't have no experience with opiates
the amount of fentanyl that can kill you
is like infinite
it's crazy so let me ask you is it is it
i'm just very fascinated by what's going
on because in my opinion right now
everyone is on some kind of drug in l.a
oh man bitch
everybody's on drugs and on steroids too
every that is correct yeah about
peptides and all sorts of stuff extreme
peptide stocks i'm on peptides which
just naturally increases a little bit of
testosterone um but uh there's okay
everyone in l.a i believe is on some
kind of cannabis edible
making it legal i am so happy for all
these cancer patients but it takes like
45 minutes now to get four miles and
it's not even in the traffic anymore
everyone is stoned out of there
you think that's what have you been to
miami lately you can get anywhere you
need to go in 12 minutes because they're
on cocaine
it's the same
busy city all right so carpool lane
cocaine
i know i know someone she's a mom and
her morning granola has uh uh thc in it
everyone is stoned all the time in l.a
i'm convinced yeah i mean it could be
true it could be true i mean i desperate
housewives that episode of um felicity
huffman doing adderall that's what got
me hooked on drugs boop is that true
yeah yeah
moms they have to juggle so much moms
have to drink related so much okay so
well that was well no i got i got hooked
uh jesse spano on say by the bell yeah
so excited so excited so so scared so
scared i'm so scared i am so scared i'm
gonna go do show girls i'm gonna do
something to really just make my life
safer in general you should oh my god
who would play her you would be a great
gina gershon correct in a show oh crap
damn crystal fucking crowners crystal
cummings great
crystal meth
there's a dragon we named crystal method
and i
i hate that name so much well it's also
a band uh or what's up
yeah
i just don't like names that have like a
full like uh i guess phenobarbital as a
drug but that's a seizure medication for
dog okay
okay i'm just fascinated in general by
the i'm spending so much time and energy
on people in los angeles and their weird
moods and weird decisions and i'm
realizing i think everyone is medicated
in some way shape or form no no no it's
not the drugs it's the moon
it's gotta be the moon it's wrong or
it's in retrograde
oh my god mercury but it's gotta don't
mercury poisoning people between the
poisoning and the retrograde
it's not the poison it's it's gotta be
the planets it's gotta be the moon
people in
um everything's going on in my life it's
i've got to be saturn my sadder in
return is like it's certainly not the
the great cocaine you just did and you
haven't slept in two days it's not your
saturn returns it's your tax returns
yeah yeah you should pay them did
i've had to remove a lot of those people
out of my life or at least distance them
i do have a very strong belief that uh
your astrological sign does say a lot
about your character but not because of
the reason that i think we all kind of
think i think it's because your
personality is formed based on your
birthday's proximity to other holidays
because then yeah because then you
either get a certain amount of attention
or not because you're like christmas but
who cares about easter so think about it
who's weirder than the person with a
birthday that's december 24th
or january 1st absolutely right but
that's what um
that's capricorns cause capricorns
they're like work focused overachievers
same as virgos because nobody cared
about their birthday because they were
too focused on the birth of my hero
jesus christ and then by the time their
birthday came along january first second
there's no money left there's no time
for parties we're back to work we don't
have time for you you're not on new
year's right so then my birthday is
september 4th which is labor day weekend
first day of school always first day of
school was my birthday so i was
basically like in class for my birthday
like sharpening my pencils
yes they're like this isn't about you
it's the first day of school right oh
man and i'm just getting smacked in the
face with my lisa frank trapper keeper
but then leo's right which are august
right
leo's they have all the attention in the
world in august you're having parties
you're at the beach like you know then
sagittarius it's even worse and then i
mean don't make us geminis gemini don't
even get me
they need a lot of physical touch
whatever i have a theory that is when
your birthday was usually over spring
break when your boyfriend was probably
cheating on you and like you were there
it was hysteronic dramatic thing
that's my theory but what about in the
rest of the world where these holidays
don't exist astrology doesn't exist
either way just a no way
well the moon's like really bright here
yeah so i don't know anyone well it was
built by stanley kubrick to fake the
moonlandic
so it's ian warner brothers
went to the moon sure sure actually the
past week has been a very fiery hot
button astrology argument
week okay i was at a wedding with this
um uh this incredible girl that i met
she was the daughter of a former mexican
president because she's so cool but she
is like she is really like hard-pilled
on astrology sure and i was just being a
fucking bitch i was like just
antagonizing and um
and i cause i actually love it too and
my it's actually my friend my great uh
my friend who is a witch like the
ultimate astrologer her birthday's today
and um gemini oh yeah and then um but
she's uh i love hearing about it from
her because she's so knowledgeable it's
like a person who knows everything about
mythology yes so they're able to apply
all those like stories and um lessons to
like life that is just interesting and
helpful the only thing that i bump on
with the hardcore astrology is my own
personal thing and insecurity and
projection which is that it only uh
applies to people whose mother was sober
and loved them because they know what
time they were born
i do not we have no evidence we have no
idea yeah i don't think anybody does
because they're like you can't really
know unless you know what time you're
born i'm like bitch we don't have my
birth certificate right none of my
family was sober or remembered like you
know so but i do believe like it's no
less valid than any religion or bible or
whatever i actually think it probably
has more value than a lot of like the
scientology certainly not raping anybody
oh when he was rising
i mean it's certainly less destructive
sure i think astrology is um
can't make it today because mercury's in
retrograde like here's what it is i
can't sign that contract yeah
i think that as long as it's like a
hobby and or just something to do i am
looking i am in the market for a cult
and i would love for it to be astrology
you know i would i would love a cult too
but i just don't want to like i don't
want to give them all my money i was um
when i got like on drag race and i kind
of when i started to get famous i was
like oh this feels like culti i feel
like the like uh the unwitting leader of
a cult and i was like i think i could do
this yeah yeah yeah yeah i think i could
do this it's super fun i don't really
know i don't have enough like drive
ambition determination or um
you don't look at any cloaks oh no i
love clothes okay
i love like smocks cloaks yeah capes
things like that dirty feet but also you
have to have sex with them and that's a
whole that's exhausting oh okay i mean
but it fits a lot of people if there's a
lot of people yeah yeah and they're
virgos what is your exact birthday
september 4 1982 september okay so
you're about to be
hit you in the face you're about to be
i'm about to be someone that's hitting
you in the face about to be i'm about to
violently threshold violently murder on
the first
i'm on the precipice of the string
facelift you're about to be taken out
back in shots
well i just turned 40 and let me tell
you tell me it's everything you want it
to be and more uh i was i mean do we get
the aarp discount
it's not
like the full bloom and blossom and
the full depth and breadth of being a
woman i love getting older which is a i
swear to god i'm not gaslighting myself
or like you know none of this body
positivity has impacted me or none of
these memes none of this inspirational
shit i just truly like it for some
reason yeah and my fake tits are
starting to fall to a good spot awesome
you know they were like they were like
crocodile eyes there for a minute like
now they're starting to look real but
i'm wondering as you get older is there
any advice that you thought was
fooey and now you're like that's true oh
that's a good question um like any good
advice you've gotten in general but at
the time you're like and now you're oh
you know what it's don't start
smoking hmm that was a great piece of
advice mm-hmm but you know
crazy kids will do what they want here's
what i'll say about do you smoke now oh
yeah okay so here's the thing about my
um
i am not condoning a smoking oh
fantastic okay made by fans oh my god
that's incredible
um i dated a pediatric anesthesiologist
once because i once made a good decision
um don't worry pediatric oh kills kids
by accident
work drugs kids drugs and grooms
children he puts them to sleep and
sometimes they don't wake up the cosby
of babies my god the medical malpractice
insurance must be
other thing
and he said such a big reason that
smoking is so relaxing is because you're
taking deep breaths no bullshit what but
yeah bullshit let me tell you
smoking is a trick okay it's a trick to
get people not to talk to you
[Laughter]
to drive people away yeah
um it's a trick
i thought about this for like 20 years
okay and it's true um it's it's a trick
story i convinced myself that this thing
will is going to make me feel better i
know it to be true yeah it's an
undisputable truth in my life yeah it's
not true because a nicotine
is not um is an addictive chemical but
it's not that much nicotine withdrawal
is nothing but what else you addicted to
about it you get to step out of the
restaurant you get to walk away you get
to be alone everything it's an addictive
it's a it's a
habit that i have um declared essential
no matter how bad my life is going to
happen no matter how bad the situation
no matter how intolerable it is i can
just go away and smoke and everything's
gonna be fine it is but it's not fine of
course it's actually worse but nicotine
also feels so good oh not that good well
i mean but you've been smoking for if i
do i take a nicotine i like if i take a
nicotine a nicotine gum nicotine gum or
a nicotine patch yeah have you ever like
just put on yeah yeah you know and then
during the pandemic i was smoking like a
pack of american spirits a day because i
appropriate i didn't want to smoke i
just want to appropriate and um it like
it just like breaks up your day in the
best way it gives you a reason to go
outside and not have to talk to anybody
it makes me feel like
creative like i'm charles bukowski or
something oh god and it is just so i
don't know what it is it's just like
you know it is a great alternative you
could actually walk outside and eat an
orange
you could walk outside and go imagine
maywest doing that
yes
to like your woods you're like
have you ever done the tooth the uh tea
tree toothpick i've done a lot of
replacement things for the cigarette and
none of them really hit that good i must
say i'm actually gonna do this quick
story i was uh uh this was i don't know
maybe like eight years ago or something
and i was uh i kind of smoked a little
bit and i was kind of trying not to but
i also had a little bit of social
anxiety and i was just getting out of a
relationship and you know you're getting
out of a bad relationship all of a
sudden you like dye your hair and you
need to get bangs and you need to get a
tattoo that says breathe i'm in a
relationship yeah
my husband talk about that in a second
show pony and then um and then these
some guy that i would like new guy that
i was dating was doing the tea tree
toothpicks because he was sober
it's toothpicks oh with like tea tree
oil and you chew on them they have
cinnamon ones too but you can like put
them in your mouth oh yeah i've had the
cinnamon you know like i have family
from the south and you just like have
toothpicks in your mouth all day right
we got two threads on our mouth
and i went to um this uh bar and met a
couple friends of mine in lee eisenberg
who he was writing on the office at the
time uh and he uh we're like talking and
i like have the toothpick in my mouth
and you just went
so it's like you're
it's like your new thing
you're doing a bit this is like a new
character it was so embarrassing and so
true it was like no one said i love it
i just have to watch this like when
trixie started wearing like hats like
fedoras i was like oh so
we're doing that now it's like when
someone decides they have a nickname and
you're like oh so we're lizzy now oh see
that's oh you're lulu now cool you're
42. you can't just like if you're not
trans and you didn't like change it it's
like it's tough because i i knew this
guy and like i he had one name and and
then he preferred to be called by an
another name that i didn't i really
didn't like
but i liked the i liked the previous
name and it was just like a personal
thing so i had to respect it but it just
bothered me no but it's like if you have
any complaints about a trans person
changing their name have you ever had a
non-trans person change their name
halfway through life and you're like
oh trying to get your name scooter now
they're trying to rebrand yeah totally
like what are we doing i was actually
trying to work out a bit about this
about how when people are like
complaining about like oh i have to say
they them or i have to learn a new
pronoun like we are so
mortified when we misgender a baby
um you know when you like see a baby and
you're like what's his name her
oh my god i'm so sorry i'm so sorry i'm
like mortified i mean i was misgendered
as a fourth grader and it was i'll never
forget it never forget it but in front
of the whole class oh that's a lot yeah
right but why is it so why is it the
ultimate humiliation for a boy to be
called a girl and now i mean i get paid
hundreds of thousands that's i was gonna
say it's not now but yeah you made it
yeah well i think it's any well the same
with me i mean
where i come from you know uh there
you're you're basically
whatever gender your older sibling was
because you had to inherit their clothes
oh sure so if you're poor you're
whatever gender your older sibling was
so i was like a tomboy because i had an
older brother but that's not humiliating
dude the extent that it is i had bigger
fish to fry right on the schoolyard what
did they say dickney cummings or uh
uh
brittany bummings shitney slummings
that's good the worst one is just
whitney cummings
but i used to do a joke because i didn't
realize how funny my name was actually
or how gross until i moved to hollywood
by the way i'm on the school yard with a
bunch of like you know i got made fun
for so many other things so i was like
so tall so young and then i moved to
hollywood and i go into like meetings
with agents i'm 20 years old i'm going
into these meetings with like men in
suits and they're like what are you
coming so i'm like what don't you own
caa like so everything was about my name
having come in it well also this is
weird emily brought this up the other
day i always forget my mom before she
married my dad her last name was coming
with no s so my mom was paddy cumming
cummings so when they got divorced i
couldn't even like pick a different name
i know blessed by the gods cummings
and cumming is the verb and cummings is
the noun
so then i had to do a joke when i first
started doing stand up where i would say
uh because people could not get past
they thought it was a stage name and i
would have to say my last name is you
know uh
whitney cummings don't worry it's just a
stage name my real last name is gumshot
you should have changed it to like like
whitney come slut or something like that
but just donkey punch yeah um let me ask
you uh a couple things i want to know
uh what you think of did you see this
person that smeared cake on the mona
lisa oh my god yeah we just talked about
the studio the other day what is
happening i why did they not do it over
the face that would be much funnier i'm
not sure i mean i don't know too much
about it so i'd love to talk about it in
depth neither do i exactly i know
absolutely nothing they're from an
expert it was um like they there was a
cheap disguise like a really like boo
boo disguise
and then throwing it was it three no it
was this guy that was like dressed up as
an old lady he obviously did not make
the cut for drag race he was very angry
yeah
and then just uh put cake all over it
yeah which i kind of have into yes
can i let them eat cake how do you get
that close to them so how are we certain
the mona lisa is not a cake it's not the
biggest like issue on the internet right
now is it she could be anybody i am 100
sure you are a cake uh yeah i mean i am
yeah i'm okay i mean i don't like the
funny thing about that kind of artwork
is like uh who's it uh fran leibovitz
was talking about it was really
interesting you know when a picasso goes
on for sale like at an auction uh it
comes out and you know it's it's viewed
and the the crowd is silent and then
when it's the final uh amount that it's
sold for that's when people start
roaring with cheer like you know
cheering it's like the money it's it's
worth is what's impressive about all
mind games like it's worth nothing
unless we think it's read something like
are you are you and yeah if you do but
diamonds
you know that's a good point because you
can't really build with diamonds or
whatever but like what can you do with a
diamond it's all socially constructed
what can you do with a diamond um
uh get a best friend what can you do
with the diamonds yeah it's all socially
constructed therefore the class warfare
happens and they're coming up the
mountain for you yeah yeah yeah bitch
what you know they're not going to be
doing my diamonds no they're going to be
eating your flesh which by the way one
time i'm just going to say this i um
come forward it's covered in sally
hansen self tanner they'll die of
mung poisoning within two seconds
uh one time i did this pilot jenna
jamison was on it remember emily was
with me yeah it's this pilot that i wish
had happened uh but it was uh it was
about what happens when uh a woman in a
relationship with a guy she starts
making more money and it fucks up the
power dynamic based on my real life
about as soon as i got a couple tv shows
on the air uh when i was like poor guys
were like cuddling my face like english
patient sex like trying to take care of
me like holding the back of my neck and
as soon as i got two tv shows on the air
spit in the face
night off no day got picked up no spit
in the face getting choked getting hair
pulled like just all the jessica simpson
ones not even the new ones um yeah it
was about that and then jenna jameson
would come in and like explain what was
going on like after it happened after
the first time i had a guy spit in my
face and she had been in your just
there's no like
no just spitting face
i spit the mouth is kind of something
there's a couple after i started earning
money or ostensibly seeming like someone
with power i was just in mma with i i
was just i would feel like well i mean
this is just dumb but i would assume the
opposite that they would like want you
to put them in diapers and like you know
what i mean like them in a bed
interesting
no it was like um i need to restore the
power dynamic maybe those guys are out
there yeah i'm sure there are cats i
remember one time this guy um he was
like a minor league baseball player and
he
he was like degrading me in all these
weird ways there was like a fish hook
that happened from behind
and a nostril no no no
and then one night i think he just like
panicked or like couldn't pick a lane
and three of his fingers just like went
in my mouth right on my teeth like
oh my god and i literally went pulled
out your veneers
he just panicked that i was going to
talk somebody ring the bell coaches come
in and we like have a crunch
need some kind of heads up i need some
direction
y'all straight people are so fucking
crazy what does that even mean straight
people are crazy
people i think street people
i was like
i mean the only reason you should feel
bad for me is that now women are
expected to eat ass and i'm um oh my god
that's so funny
i just said well i cancelled the
subscription but i recently subscribed
to a whole website about girls doing
that okay
subscribe
yeah like i paid like paid for it okay
yeah that's the darkest part
no i want to support small businesses
that's sweet and also that helps them
those girls small restaurants yeah you
know what i mean they're like yeah it
would be worth it to steal it and then
nobody's going to try to that's true you
can't still parties but wait is that a
porn site where it's just girls eating
ass pretty much i it's interesting it
doesn't get like super they're not super
degree a lot of the girls don't seem
they're they're acting of course sure um
but some of the girls it are pretty
convincing and the guys are like it's
funny sometimes because they're just
like
yeah i just don't i get i break out
do you ever get mask knee i mean from
the mask eating i'm saying oh yeah yeah
i'm saying eating ass to me seems like
there's going to be butt cheeks that
sweaty butt cheeks on your chin and i
don't want to break out along with you
it's a very i mean it's a it's a
it's contingent on the on extremely like
um up to the minute hygiene yeah yeah
which i guess is part of the ritual of
it
but i just i
work too hard
and there's some things i'm just i can't
because i don't want to have to
worry about i don't want to have to be
insecure uh you know
and baby wipes clog up your toilet
oh yeah i mean i just stuff them down
the sink
i'm just kidding
[Music]
i just eat them yeah i was um oh sorry
guys i was just gonna ask what is going
on out there in the dating apps are you
dating oh my lord
recently tinder and
i would say 70 of the people had some
kind of scuba mask on
what
like some kind of
like duct tape wrapped head like some
kind of
uh to show that they're fun or like they
have activity it was a lot of like
looking for a third and i think it's
become very dom sub
oh wow okay and on tinder i think so
okay it wasn't like fetlife or whatever
i like borrowed a friend's thing yeah i
mean i i here's the thing i have been
i've never had a boyfriend for more than
three months never had a serious
relationship i'm 40. and i
like it i don't know i actually do i
mean because i will i often get lonely
and i'll often like rome i i'm a huge
romantic uh fantasy person but um i know
enough about the reality of of living
with people and spending a lot of time
with them that it's like
now what
there are there's good times and then
there's a lot of not great times and so
i mean i love being alone me too i love
having really good friends and i love
working with like cool people and i like
traveling or being able to go travel and
not have to worry about anything but um
i don't know you're full i'm like
totally totally you get your emotional
needs met internally yes and then
everything else happens from these
little gifts you gave me hey girl taking
a break from cocktail
to talk to you about
shake a shaky shake you know what that
is
emily
i was jumping up and down it's my dried
up bags
they're like pebbles in there
they're half people pebbles
quick question guys just curious does
your probiotic contain clinically
studied strains definitely not no grace
is definitely definitely not no everyone
in texas knows that grace's underwear
contains stains
not straight this should be clinically
stealthy ours cars contain dust but look
ritual you guys know i've been taking
the omega oils for ages not allowed to
tell you about all the benefits but just
look at me
the new product is a probiotic but it's
more than a probiotic
because no one has time for just a lousy
program it's called a one biotic no it's
a three in one right okay it's like it's
a um pansexual
uh why pick one if you could have three
with a clinically it's an orgy
it's an orgy of good bacteria it's an
orgy of biotics clinically studied
prebiotics probiotics and a postbiotic
which i didn't even know existed to
support a balanced gut microbiome
one daily capsule for simple streamlined
gut support delayed release capsule
designed to help reach the colon not the
stomach thank you for the ideal place
for probiotics to survive and grow it
might be the only thing that's ever
growing inside me
take it away inside me
symbiotic and ritual are here to
celebrate not hide your insides are they
gonna murder me and cut me open
synbiotic plus
there is no more shame in your gut game
well grace there isn't yours not soon to
be fixed by it that's why ritual is
offering my listeners and only mine i
can't listen to anyone else grace is
listeners okay 10 off during your first
three months visit ritual.com whitney to
start ritual or add symbiotic plus to
your subscription to today
speaking of today i have shows to
promote june 24th i'll be in calgary
alberta at prince island's park june
26th i'll be at toronto ontario danforth
music hall i think that's sold out but
we'll remember it it is indeed sold out
really released some tickets some people
are gonna squeeze them in july first
west hampton beach new york oh yeah i'm
gonna go to tim dillon's for the weekend
in the hamptons and do west hampton
beach new york the west hampton beach
performing arts center come get lyme
disease with me
september 8th i'll be in cincinnati ohio
at the taft theater i'm 99 sure i'm
gonna make that flight guys
september 9th ooh
wait
five days after my birthday
two days before 9 11.
[Laughter]
as dan minsman said my birthday's my
birthday's on 9 11 which really sucks
like what am i gonna have two parties
uh on september 9th i'll be in
philadelphia pennsylvania at the merriam
theater
theater changed names no it's the miller
theater it's not the movie it was the
miriam now it's the miller but it either
works just google it i'm sure you guys
are still calling it this yeah nerd
alert sorry guys i'm just trying to get
you to the right venue we sent a lot of
people to miami florida when we were in
oklahoma emily does have a weirdly
genius sense of direction which makes no
sense given her
chromosome
layout september 10th i'll be in
richmond virginia by the way spiders at
the national is that real yeah oh yeah
go spiders
god stop spiders the only animal i kill
sight unseen i had a fucking black widow
i was with you you crushed it that's
right put the book back in the basket
and left the carnage on this library
floor yes i i want the other spiders to
know yeah yeah that's smart i leave that
on the spike yeah i leave the dead
spider so other spiders are like uh-oh
don't fuck with this bitch right it was
a black widow
i didn't know a full black widow with
the red thing on it it's a good thing
it's a future white widow because i will
murder my future husband it's a good
thing we have insurance or black widows
all over this place
oh i thought you meant my personal
liability umbrella insurance which means
i can say fuck you koch brothers in
purdue the black widows well sewer
photos are coming for you
september 24th charlottesville virginia
the paramount theater by the way i was
looking at real estate in uh west uh in
richmond last night really
back to katya i want to ask you because
i um asked this to everyone on the
podcast you seem to have a very
sagacious um clear idea of what is toxic
in people sedation
like
like um you are very smart and true to
the decisions you make yes like wise you
have good a good gut instinct about
people i do well for example when i
first asked you this podcast you said no
that means you have good instincts yeah
yeah but then then i come become
desperate for attention and i came in
and then i started just having super
famous people on to make me feel left
out yeah it's like she's rich maybe i
should know her
um red flags in people as you've gotten
more successful and as people probably
are trying to use you
and get close to you and gussy up to you
i mean that i mean i'm not that rich
like it it's it's i mean like there's
obviously a difference in your life 10
years ago what is a red flag in people i
for example i throw some out on every
podcast uh clear your bra straps
on a weekday
red flag mary that's insane honey you're
crazy i'm just saying it would mean a
red flag that's a that's a um that's
what you call that that's a um
um a uh
pet peeve or something that is like if i
see someone in a tube top clear
well i'm just like you're not
ready worthy of love and you can't
you're not
you're not worthy of love like i can't
count on you as a person
you are that's a little how do you not
have the thank you
you should at least have the stickiest
post-it bra that is like the you know
you should tape them down like everybody
else
just get some duct tape like an adult
how about that um
here's my new one
people that trash kim kardashian a lot
that's a red flag for me okay yeah i
think uh well i mean a similar one is
like people who
hate like um
people who like needlessly trash like
popular music for example yeah yeah
especially music because it's like i
mean girl like please yes there's so
many different kinds of music there's so
much bad music and this isn't for you
yeah it's for brazil and i feel like um
there's also
like someone that wears heels to the
airport um
that's puzzling if however however
though i mean i certainly do not
understand anything rushing from a thing
to a thing if you're going if london uh
heathrow there's so much walking from
the in the terminal there's so much it's
like a mile correct or more sometimes in
these airports i just don't understand
how you do it i mean i don't understand
how anybody does it he throw more like
hamilt hammered my little clickers i
want to feature that thank god these are
out but look at these little clickers
will you please hold these up to the
camera so what is happening here so
we've got a a classic little um
chunky heel mule and then just glued a
whole bunch of shit on there yes
bedazzled and how long does it take you
to do this how many adderall you need to
be involved how many riddles milligrams
a day for about six weeks
[Laughter]
okay yes like a heel like i'm talking
three and a half inch eat shit mary you
i think that's probably just more
indicative of masochism but again i
can't count on you oh no i'm talking
about red flags for people that you're
gonna allow into your life as you move
forward someone you're going to
literally litter literally
that's a big big oh okay oh two things
rude to a waiter waitress disgusting
rude to a server um even even i mean and
i'm talking the this like my uh metric
for rudeness is is pretty fierce
if you
wait who is that i love that it doesn't
tip well oh
dinner with someone recently lovely
lovely guy
fussy fussy eater there's nobody fussier
than me with eating why what um i'm
super picky and i hate all food why
i don't know can we come back to that
i'm fascinated okay but so i i am very
like um i plan and i'm like aware of
what you know if something comes and i
don't like it i'm either just gonna
leave it there or put it in the back
or whatever i'm not going to complain
about it right i'm certainly going to
pay for it i'm going to over tip that's
correct it's just a thing but if like
complaining uh certainly causing any
kind of scene um being rude snippy or
passive aggressive to a server eat shit
my nightmare die my nightmare um also
what was the first thing i said uh uh um
oh litter litter uh give a hoot yeah no
litter bugs gotta go except i litter
with my cigarette butts
what's your punishment going to be but
you just flicked it
in the pool doesn't someone um listen
here's what you know the cock and the
groud on your face will clog my pool
yeah
[Laughter]
the sherwin
semi-gloss
yeah
um no but the uh
if i see a trash can absolutely yeah
absolutely sometimes i don't see one but
let me ask you a question
sometimes i close my eyes and i just
don't see one yeah i remember growing up
we would i mean my dad would be driving
us to virginia from dc but like finish a
can of sprite just throw it out the
window my friend dave with a whole bag
of mcdonald's mcdonald's
like he had literally just mowed a woman
down with his car i mean it felt that
serious i was like oh my god what
monster that's a really good one um this
is another one people who
brag about like not having tv as if
they're better than you so oh yeah so
what are you doing on your own you're a
dragon without tv i don't i don't watch
tv i don't have it
it's like i read faulkner cool yeah
cool what are you reading like old man
in the sea yeah like 17th century uh
french poetry cool you're the best i'm
so sorry to have bothered you with
talking about television i actually
prefer the opposite i don't read
i don't like fucking books like fuck you
you know like i just like that that's
better i want to call myself out on
something lately which is that i will
now talk about having watched a
documentary as if i had read a book
well i mean is it the same thing yet
well let's not uh just some a lot of
books are shit
yeah you know so a lot of documentaries
are much more well researched and well
done then
and also like more well absorbed yeah by
the humanity the arrogance with which i
will discuss having watched a
documentary that someone has not watched
how beneath me i believe they are
yeah you literally get on a step stool
and like talk about i was i'm like hey
like i talked hey dumb dude make a wish
kid let me talk to you
about fire festival it's the dark
matters aren't even on anything smart
and i'm just like think i'm like a
scholar
what's the uh best documentary or like
maybe top one just in general oh my gosh
this is a really good one do you
remember the imposter um
so sorry so sorry no please uh no the
impossible oh
uh the art forgery uh oh that mm-hmm the
imposter was i am spoiling this sorry
guys um this has been out for 10 years
and you haven't seen it i'm not doing
that spoiler you have a month to see
yeah
okay so it's about a guy
a child that was kidnapped in texas or
like mysteriously disappeared when he
was 15 and then there was this belgian
guy who was kind of just like a foster
kid criminal and at 25 he was like if
you are
uh uh in foster care and running around
and doing bad shit
in most countries i believe it is when
you're 18 then you just go to prison
because they don't know where else to
like put you
so he goes to prison they're about to
send him to another high security
president because he tried to shank
someone whatever it was he's i believe
armenian uh by dissent and they're about
to change him to this other super high
security prison where you just get raped
within the interest of your life and
everybody gets like murdered like random
like belgium and so he goes through the
files in the um missing person office
for the missing persons all over the
world and dyes his hair to look like
this missing kid that was 15. this guy
is 25 years old
is of armenian descent dark skin big ass
fucking ears dyes his hair to try to
look like this kid scribbles on a couple
of the same tattoos and says i'm this
kid
the family's like we've been looking for
our son for all this time they go to
belgium
see him he looks nothing like the kid
and the sister's like that's him that's
my baby
that's him they bring him back into the
home and the guy who's pretending to be
the child goes into the child's family
home and is like this is fucked up like
i'm not your son and they would not
allow him to believe that he wasn't
and they like went on the news and so
there's some
watch the rest but that's kind of
incredible uh the woman who wasn't there
is amazing it's the woman who pretended
she was in 911 and she wasn't evil
genius the woman that masterminded a
bomb to go around a man's neck a pizza
guy
i love shit like that oh yeah i can't
watch those crime ones because it just
gets me all
hard no i have to be too weird
to be hard all day long
who's the hottest man on earth to you
right now
i'm gonna say mine i'm on top go ahead
who's yours tom hardy okay yeah yeah his
face makes me hungry oh yeah i he was um
he was mine for a while but then the
last thing i saw him in he's a little
too rugged oh a little too like it looks
like he's gonna like slash my throat
okay
dangerous
um but i would say
oh god did you see succession
uh i i know i know who's in it though
who um i thought adrian brody was
weirdly hot this year in succession i i
don't i don't find him attractive i like
uh i like a giant i like a picat
no he's got a very he's got a huge nose
and my friend is like obsessed with with
large features i mean i like large
features um i like um oh yes the
starbucks barista eight thousand sunset
wait so barista okay like it i'm vibing
um so i am available though okay and um
he's probably literally half my age um
i'm dating a man that's nine years
younger than me
so yeah i know i'm saying by the way i
would like to just
i mean it's i hate this age thing it's
can i the thing we do not talk about
enough is ages and we talk about sexism
racism homophobia all that ageism is a
big one i know it because i am over like
if i weren't famous um especially like
gay famous and walked into a gay space
looking the way i do how to drag oh my
god invisible
absolutely invisible and i mean
if i had hair and like you know i need
to draw on my eyebrows and stuff i mean
depending on like the state of my health
i mean i can look i look like fine
whatever but it's like it's the old
thing people are really really focused
on like just young young or they have
like if they fetishize like daddies or
whatever uh-huh so you're like kind of
in between yeah it was at least for the
wrong person
huh
at least for the wrong person yeah i
kind of find it very i like getting
older also because it weeds out the
people that care about age because most
people are duds i like getting older
because when someone's attracted to me
i'm like i think you're cool for being
into me because i'm not 21. uh-huh like
i like you where's all the guys that i
did when i was 21. i was like well you
just like me because i'm turning around
like you like a guy who's into older
ones yes now i'm into you because you're
into me well i mean it's i don't know i
just think it's so dumb and i thought it
was like a cliche about l.a but it is
for real here like it is
everything is about youth and looking
younger and it's just like i mean it's
the the marketing and all that bullshit
it's really it's really really insane
and i'm also like buying into it yeah
you know but
i don't know i just wish we'd glamorize
oldies and not all these who look good
right not just like paulina poroscova
who is like hasn't had you know is
willing to be naked enough she was also
a supermodel yeah yeah you know but um
she can be part of the movement but i
want oldies are you so are you
actively
engaging in anti-aging practices
or what i mean how do you anti-age well
i'm doing the nad the nmn resveratrol
cryo freeze steam okay sauna
and ulthera
is and baby's blood
adrenochrome do you booty bump it or
just drink it like chug it from the
gallon booty bump the babies yeah blood
well the animal it's so absorbent oh
right no i don't need ass
adults or babies asses
of the baby is all the stuff real that
you just said yes i mean i don't do all
that but i do wear human teeth on my
nails so i'll be like you know
there's that all comes out in the water
is that and then whose teeth are those
i don't know they're just um i'm not
really sh i'm not really sure where the
the teeth were sourced from they do look
like adult molars though okay so was
this a craigslist purchase or no no i i
was like i made a stupid post on twitter
it was like i think like i want some
teeth or whatever and then um they just
kept
they they kept coming and they didn't
stop do you think people uh removed them
to send them to you or do you think they
were already oh i hope i don't get in
there bloody and wet you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah no okay i wanna also know the
hottest woman to you right now oh gosh
okay well like who do you look at and
you're like ugh so many it's tough and
also now just in general oh okay
michelle pfeiffer 1995 oh my god have
you seen her oh my god have you seen her
instagram now
yeah her um she has like a perfume line
henry rose and yeah and she'll just like
talk about mixing the fragrances
together wait it's so funny like qvc
is so white i can't stop because she's
she's so above what she's doing but
she's so passionate about she's got four
fragrances
she's got a roller and she'll and it's
like it is so impossible to understand
because it's like the one sense we can't
get you can't smell it with the phone
bitch
and she's like really trying to describe
it oh my god
and you
it is the only thing we cannot
understand based on what you were saying
but she's so in it
she's so in it and looks so stunning i i
mean i love so many i think um angelica
houston angelica
it was i mean sharon stone in basic
instinct these the the divas of the 90s
the real like uh superstar actresses
have you seen the clip of sharon stone
uh being asked if she was sexually
harassed were you ever
in a position
like that where you did that you felt
that you were
uncomfortable
you're laughing but i i don't know
i don't know if that's a nervous laugh
or are you kidding me of course i was
laugh i've been in this business for 40
years lee
worked
so i mean she obsessed yeah she there
was a recently on her instagram um
i think her getting ready at can like
with her her glam team like
this is what it takes
to get
she just crushes it
crushes
it so how stunning
um uh obsessed and then where like
growing up who was your like icon
of uh for women
yeah just in general like who would you
like
oh god i think well i think my name is
christy charlie
who christy charlington i wasn't so much
into models but i was like i was into
actresses yeah big time and i saw all
the 90s divas like susan sarandon um uh
michelle pfeiffer um uh cher kim
basinger
i was like i love that julie brown um
with on mtv people like kim bassinger
yeah um
my stepmother's an alien recently it is
one of the most incredible comedic
performances by any actress in any movie
yeah love fucking nicole kidman although
she's more of a recent thing and then um
nicole kidman has looked the same age
for truly 20 years oh you know who also
has um fucking sandra bernhard she's
been 45 for 73 years huh like i saw her
at the netflix uh the gay comedy special
and she has looked like herself yes for
40 years yes yes i mean she's not
exactly a swimsuit cover model yeah yeah
but great because then she can just
maintain this like recognizable face yes
and she looks so good there's something
great about
when i always looked older
when i was in my 20s people always
thought i was in my 30s and now that i'm
in i look young i caught up to my face
yeah i feel like she might have looked a
little bit older maybe because it was
her maturity and confidence she was 50
and she looked 40. and now she kind of
has this ageless 70 she'll look 40 yeah
100 totally concur yeah she's uh that
was great um oh i also loved um i mean i
was a huge gymnastics fan so i was like
obsessed with carrie struck
carrie struck carrie strug i mean big is
this your kerry's drug moment the moment
kerry strugg stuck the landing with a
broken ankle that is the way that i
moved through life is going you stick
the landing with a broken ankle and a
smile on your fucking face yeah and not
then you get annoyed by your coach later
i was gonna say
once and then and then because you
realize like okay that's what nbc is
that is the glorious picture their their
heroic you know portrayal that they're
like jizzing over and that they they
portray for you
but then when you like
start to learn about the corollas like
her coach and um
the just like the systematic abuse like
that it was just so horrible could it
just i hate that shit i i i mean
oh bitch wanna talk about documentary
tell me oh
i watched all of them i don't know it
became like an obsession
and i have never he never went to jail
right now
okay he is in jail um
but there was i have never felt so much
like um
empathy i suppose like and i haven't i
haven't been abused or anything i'm
never like that but i've i felt so much
empathy because i just love these
athletes these girls so much and i was
just like
oh oh i want to kill oh i wanted to kill
oh i wanted to kill and there was a guy
who one of the uh victim's dog
dads was in the courthouse oh i remember
that yeah and he almost like rushed
out let him do it
let him go by the way that's a big thing
in prison well i mean prisoners prison
if you are a pedophile molest um
children and you go to jail
you not a lot of sympathy there people
that murdered their wives and and
conducted
shot at post offices want to fucking
kill you like that's even criminals
think it's wrong and that's what they do
diabolical when uh the prison guards
when a pedophile comes in and uh in the
prison yard or whatever when people go
after them they just let it happen you
know but so crazy it's fascinating
because um i played really competitive
basketball and
the parents were so all over everything
all the time and it was like these
helicopter parents where you're like why
isn't that the case in gymnastics are
they not allowed around
they were in the room sometimes
in the fucking room and they just didn't
didn't he was so diabolical he was so
diabolical that he even made
instructional tapes on this because he
was so well studied and like um learned
that uh he knew what he was talking
about he could convince someone to their
face while he was literally like
fingering their fucking daughter that
i'm realizing her spine yes it was all
very medical all very professional all
very convincing
and then oh that is sick
sometimes with the parent in the fucking
room and he's getting an erection it is
absolutely satanic shit satanic shit and
the worst like one of the worst things
is that some of the girls like um would
be like you know they would call uh
older girls who had had the same you
know same stream by him and they're like
yeah you know i think like sometimes
something felt weird and they're like oh
no no no
they would um they would rationalize it
minimize it yeah and they would actually
cause like it to so they caused it to
continue and then the guilt that they
felt when it all blew up was like
unbelievable because there is also this
like uh cognitive dissonance when you're
that competitive in a uh sport like that
that is so
traumatic to the body where you're like
oh i'm like i'm literally cracking
cartilage that's inflamed and we you
know like i'm draining blisters oh and
now we're gonna put the finger in the
position he was the good guy l4 yeah he
was the good guy because
all the coaches many of the coaches were
physically and mentally abusive and so
he was the one who was gonna he was
gonna take care of them he was super
nice he was like he was the sanctuary
from all that of the yelling and they're
like you you're fat you're not getting
up you're never gonna you know wow he
was the safe place he was the soft
landing oh if you want to kill him i
don't want to kill anybody but i would
have killed him
and it is also tricky because in
something that i'm all for um
like i'm in to make a winner you have to
you know
what look
i'm just saying you gotta kill me i
think it's funny because no one molested
me um but i get i i think that it's it's
as someone that i remember after
watching cheer on netflix i'm not sure
if you ever saw that it was about the
best cheerleading team it's it's
gymnastics basically but you know cheer
it's great and uh and there was this one
um
athlete gabby butler and her parents are
really hard on her they drive her really
hard and like she's the best in the
world at this like you can't just cut
you know you do have to
have people driving you and pushing you
really hard um so even while saying that
it is just
so fucked though it's like why are there
so few female gymnastics coaches
i don't think that's true i don't know i
feel like i'm always seeing some russian
guy in a uh
bond dutch pants with orange stitching
on the side i mean i know they're
well they're always jumping into the
arms there is a some old guy yeah i know
it's like with that now like looking
back knowing what we do now it's like
ooh
but um there's actually well there's a
fierce female um
uh rhythmic gymnastic coach there's a
documentary called over the limit
this is so fierce you gotta watch it
looking she is absolutely
horrible this woman and she was given
like the metal like this highest honor
from the sport uh federation in in
russia margarita
yes so her irina viner the um her coach
is like uh she's known for producing
gold medals you know she's just she gets
the gold and she's calling you fat cow
you're worthless i mean just it's insane
and she's this character and you can
tell that she's like
she's this documentary is being filmed
she knows it's all being taped and she's
just being this
mega cunt and then the poor girl is like
suffering suffering suffering her dad
dies with cancer it's like a whole thing
and she wins a gold medal
and it's literally like it's tricky
because it's like it's not a glorious
moment it's that's that is devastating
to like here but i'm just so curious if
that if she has a method to the madness
it's obviously verbal abuse but it's
like the um serena williams's dad i
remember he did an interview on howard
stern i didn't see the movie um that
will smith uh uh portrayed him in but
said that he used to pay people to go
down when they were playing tennis and
scream the n-word at them basically and
scream at them and just so that they
when they got into an actual game they
wouldn't be distracted like they were so
desensitized to it that they would stay
focused and stay motivated and so he
would pay people to basically verbally
abuse them
to make them tougher but that's more of
a racial thing chelsea must be paying
those people to do that to me and myself
i think so i certainly know about the
russians
[Laughter]
hey everyone me again i know
i know you just wish i talk more i get
that
we're taking a little break from katya
because personally i need one
um she's talking too much being way too
funny so
uh i want to talk to you guys about my
least favorite subject i hate talking
about this uh my dogs oh i know i hate
it i hate it it's torture it's torture
for me yeah yeah who cares
right right they're just dogs who have
five it's not like they're your kids
right right right my mother's just a
hassle you wouldn't eat your kid in an
apocalypse
maybe you though
whitney what are you what do you feed
your dog babies yeah i know i knew i
knew you secretly were obsessed
cause i've been snacking on something
downstairs that tastes a little off
[Laughter]
so look i am a psycho about what goes in
my dog's bellies did you know that even
if a dog food claims to be organic or
premium it contains 50 to 64 processed
cereal by-products cooked at high
temperatures that rob them of
nutritional value true dr marty
goldstein loved this guy
he has been a pioneer
in the pet nutrition space and he
finally just figured out a way he made a
food that solves all of the problems
that i have with dog foods the whole
point about dog food is just feed them
what they would eat if they were in the
wild so my dogs i have three very large
three well who's listening yeah animal
control i have three mm-hmm uh everyone
else is six or seven and also um what's
really important for dogs teeth is they
need something that's like hard enough
to like exfoliate their teeth but they
also need something that's soft enough
to not uh destroy their stomachs that's
not just trash so thank you dr marty uh
goldstein for making this easy for a
limited time save 50 off your first
order go to
doctormartypets.comwhitney that's dr
martypets.com whitney or text whitney to
5 11 5 11. that's
they offer 100 90 day return of your
purchase price text
w-h-i-t-n-e-y to 5-11-511 or go to
doctor is that how tall you are 5 11.
one sip of wine emily
you had you had one sip of one but
you're 5 11. right
not a good day where did is that what
you think that's based on just saying
what are the odds no i'm going to use
all finding connections i used to be 5
10 and
and i'm now five nine which means this
business beat me down text w-h-i-t-n-e-y
to 511-511 or go to dr martypets.com
whitney today and say fifty percent off
your first order disclaimer text fee's
made my boyfriend is five two okay so i
can't be five eleven
but he's a giant of a man disclaimer
text fees may apply you may receive up
to one additional text text to stop
text stop to opt out
and we lost her can you please take a
probiotic or something if you guys don't
want to listen to this podcast we have a
suggestion for another podcast to check
out what the fuck
what the fuck
these hoes ain't loyal
i don't know you know how i care about
transitions i didn't know how to
transition to this look
wondery
is a brilliant you should just subscribe
to wandery by the way i did the uh bunga
bunga podcast for them so it's obviously
a quality network they hired me
wondering is bringing you a new podcast
it's called call me curious it finally
gives you definitive answers to life's
burning
questions like why does it burn when i
pee that's not on the prompter
other questions like does intermittent
fasting work should i buy crypto no no
we're all on 24 7 information overload
that is true on our news feeds in our
inboxes our tick tocks our periscopes
our myspaces it's so hard to know what's
real and what isn't when it comes to
health pop culture and relationships and
call me curious cuts through the crap
nikki fills you in on the internet's
hottest debates listen to call me
curious on apple podcasts amazon music
or wherever you listen to your podcasts
you can listen early and ad free by
subscribe i'm going into my wondery
voice i like it this is what i did for
bungabung
you can listen early and add free by
subscribing to wondering plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app tip of the
teeth top of the tongue
back to katya see i could be less
annoying if i wanted to i just don't
i think that every time i'm on the phone
i can't be proposed to every day
true
do you enjoy your life do i enjoy my
life yeah
yes
every day
not all day every day no but every day
yeah i think i have so many tools so
i've been in allen on 12-step program
for
almost like 14 years now so i know how
to get myself out of it because if i
don't i'm usually feeling sorry for
myself or uh trying to victimize myself
or i'm telling myself an old story or i
need to halt i'm hungry angry lonely or
tired yeah exactly what was the last
time you cried
um i cried uh give me a second i just
did a tv show in toronto where i had to
cry all day every day and then oh i did
for myself yeah for acting what do you
do
i
do that i'm always about to cry i can
pretty much cry whenever i need to on
camera feel the same way but not when
there's cameras i know i basically my
dad died very abruptly and we were there
was a kind of a lack of closure and i
just look at a picture of him
okay yeah yeah and i just crying is
super contagious to be so if somebody
cries let's start crying so don't do it
yeah okay um i'm all dried up um from
the amount of caffeine i drank before
you came because i was worried i was
gonna be slow um but it's uh i that but
when did i cry about something actually
this is a weird thing i just shot my
fifth stand-up special oh wait wait
how'd that go i wanted to ask you thank
you for having me it went very well
did you do it uh newark new jersey what
i know i think i'm that well like my
joke my only joke about it was um so
many comedians now are getting so much
publicity around getting assaulted on
stage so i shot my special newer to make
sure i got assaulted on stage
um nobody gets out of line i think i'm
going to call it live from newark
because i just oh that's fine i just
think it's silly watching newark it's
sunday afternoon a lot of specials now
are just like everything is like nine
puns in a row which i love but i kind of
wanted to do one that was just sort of
like this is just stand up i'm not
telling you how to vote i'm not
preaching to you it's not secretly a ted
talk marketed as comedy like it's just
fucking jokes it's just dicks and
pussies
what was going on
we're silly goo airplane food and um
after the second show there's all and
it's happened every time after you i
should just it is sort of like this
weird it's like it's like having pushing
out a baby it's like nine months it's
like finally out and there's just this
like i just like went back to my hotel
room it was just kind of like sobbing
just because you're like
there's no way that's going to be as
perfect as i wanted it to be i put a
year of my life into that like it's just
a little bit of a like release of yeah
how many shows uh leading up to it had
you done like a hundred and something of
the same show
well i changed the order like i did i
think it was like 76 cities since last
june and then around town you know
and then you kind of start over but
there's a little bit of like when you
finish something or finish a tour you
just finished a tour right uh the first
leg of it yeah so it's like the you know
when's the prosthetic leg uh we have
yeah the we have the wooden leg and now
we get so there's it goes until i think
the middle of next year almost that's
wild so it's a lot but it's you know it
changes and it's not just me so that's
right doing it it's just you you have an
opener
yes the opener does like 20 minutes and
then i'll do like 60 70. yeah yeah it's
i mean it's tough being on stage by
yourself
it's way tougher for me to share the
stage in limelight with someone else
that sounds like my nightmare would you
ever do like could you ever do uh like a
uh
i don't know if they even do that like
like a pen and teller
sick breed and roy
do you like tigers
my favorite thing about that entire uh
rigmarole is that the reason that the
tiger turned on him is because of a
woman's beehive hairdo in the front row
the tiger was like stressed out by it
that's that's it i've had it and said i
don't like that woman's hairdo
bitch it was just like it was like a
fucking rat's nest and then grabbed
sigford it was like we're out of here i
mean i fantasize i deeply deeply desire
to drop dead on stage i mean it's it's
very
within the realm of possibility
i don't want to do it like on purpose
you know i don't want but i just i would
love for that i just love that to happen
there could be no better way to go i
know imagine how do you think you're
going to die
well
my witch friend who's uh says drowning
but that could mean so much things like
aspirating on vomiting i was going to
say in what how glamorous like like
hendricks drowning or like rivera
drowning so i immediately thought of
being dropped from a helicopter into the
middle of the pacific ocean at night
which would be so terrifying but why
would that happen no idea but she didn't
say like she didn't give me any context
mm-hmm so
anyway she said water
you're gonna drown in water
okay yeah it's um it's possible by the
way by the time you die there will be no
water left on earth so actually i don't
think this is why are you planning on
moving to florida no i think we're gonna
see some real shit i mean some really
real shit i think coastal cities will be
underwater in our lifetime from what i
gather i think this city is going to be
where would you live if you didn't live
in l.a
uh
i'd probably live in
um
maybe europe not where
france or i don't know the weather sucks
but maybe like
um
yeah like
south dakota have you been to berlin
yeah i don't really like it that much i
don't like german it is a little cold
yeah and the german the language it's so
hard and i don't like the way it sounds
i know so many droplets
it's too much it's a lot of spitting
yeah although we're learning mandarin
and it's real is that correct uh yeah
we're super good at it now i mean pretty
basically fluent this is wait this is
big elizabeth holm's energy right now
i mean does she not look like kind of
elizabeth holmes in a big way if i told
you
learning mansion is it because you
believe the chinese are going to take
over and you want to be able to get in
on the ground floor no it's just because
i want elizabeth holmes out of prison
okay yeah so mandarin and it's really
helpful and useful wow
i mean are you doing it in uh like a
rosetta stone kind of situation pimsleur
so it's gonna take about what two weeks
yeah to learn the entire thing
three maybe three i don't know
um uh this will be my last uh thing i
bring out because i'm gonna be
respectful and get you out of here um uh
which is before you start melting before
but i'm already melting i'm fine okay
really because i look like a different
candle really sweaty and i was very
worried but now i'm great okay really
you just adapted yeah um uh i forgot
what i was going to say oh well um
i wanted to ask you something too we
already heard horoscopes oh i also want
to know what your um uh movie i know
because you and uh trixie watch uh tv
together we also i have a book to
promote no we're going to talk about all
about this yes that's this last question
before we talk about working girls
trixie and katya's guide to professional
womanhood and then so okay so the second
one what is uh the difference between
the first and the second one how about
that well the second one is more of um
like uh if the first book was the debut
then you could call this one kind of a
sequel you know it's like it's not quite
the first it's not really the third it's
kind of in the middle so it's the l
fanning yes okay so the second one and
then when you guys write about work say
it again mostly about work okay so it's
working girls because we like to work it
yes you do you know how working girls
are like fierce y'all are animals you
work so much no she does i'm the um
i'm like the antidote to her ambition i
like the the um
like you know when the in nightmare on
elm street where um the stairs get all
like marshmallowy yeah too tasty and it
slows her down
i'm like those stairs to her admission
so like i need to keep her like okay i'm
going too fast copy do you remember um
the show animaniacs i think so uh member
pinky in the brain yeah yeah yeah pinky
and the brain
yeah she would i would be the dumb one
yeah the brain is always trying to
figure out these these like schemes big
schemes to escape and then pinkie's
always fucking it up
so they stay in the cage
um but yes i mean she is i cannot
believe it she truly is a work i want to
say workaholic like whatever i don't
think anything's going wrong yeah yet um
so but she gets out of that what you get
out of your cigarettes
like yeah she works i smoke you know
it's like the same thing yeah i mean i
literally live for the moments in
between working like the breaks yeah
vacations like the like downtime it's
like my my work day starts around
3 30 p.m it ends around five or six um
but it's it's just like
i've achieved all my like goals i love
that like so
i feel like i've been done for a long
time yeah so now you're just like
enjoying the this is i think the best
and most grateful way to be successful
because i see so many people that have
accomplished so much and then there's
just children and i'm like i don't even
know who this is for this feels like
diminishing marginal returns it also
feels like doing the same thing over and
over again expecting a different result
like you're just hate fucking what
you're doing and it's like i i did it
for longest time too is where i was just
like you know spinning my wheels as a
workaholic and i was just like oh the
person whose approval i wanted is dead
my dad and like i can just stop and
enjoy it a little bit you know go mung
diving go dip your face in on ladies
that's how you're gonna drown in mung
oh my god that's it it's so obvious
choking on dead juice you are going to
die high as fuck you are gonna drown in
formal to hide wow i mean you do get i
don't know why i'm saying it but yeah
actually that could be true yeah well my
my friend she's like she told me about
it she's like
don't do it
and she was very serious like she's like
don't just really promise me you won't
do it
i don't think i have anybody who would
jump on the corpse much like no i've
accomplished all my goals yeah yeah yeah
somebody better dive my corpse i don't
really need to do that
um okay wait what's the um what's the
thing in your life you're the most proud
of
and don't see those gorgeous tits that
eye contact that we just assigned for
good that's the longest i've ever held
eye contact with anyone my eyes are so
dry i need to blink um oh i want to talk
to you about this these new eye drops
have you seen the botox eye drops the
needles in the eye no it's like tell me
more
it's called um i can't remember what's
called demtik or something and it's like
an eye drop so you don't have to close
your eyes it opens your eyes up a little
bit yeah it makes it so because when i
get bored my eyes start like just
closing and it just keeps sleeping it
just keeps them open but sometimes you
have to keep them open when someone's
talking and it's hard for me to do and
then i end up having to just stand and
then i do that because you heard these
eye drops they keep you interested yeah
they they or they give other people the
impression you're still interested
yeah so sometimes when i'm talking to
someone i have to like well i'm a
bloodshot diva famously and i'm always
super good why are you using the lumify
no i just got it yeah and it was like so
i mean gigi gorgeous from dandelion
conditions like under i mean healthy not
healthy you know yeah yeah they've been
red red red and i put a little uh two
drops of those things in i was like wait
and then i was like
mary you it's wild
you look like a little lamb and i know
there's like a thing i've read about it
but i forget um but yeah it's wild what
are you most proud of and then i'll have
my answer oh um
um oh i forgot it
um
it was something my perfectionism is
going to come in and the opposite of
that what's the opposite of
perfectionism like that's good enough
honestly
um what is the opposite of perfectionism
laziness
no perfectionism i was gonna say
self-esteem
um self-worth being bad yeah and
understanding yeah
um
uh addiction to mediocrity
not doing good yeah i
i think here's what i'm gonna say i
think it is uh i mean i've been in a
12-step program for 14 years where i'm
able to
comport myself under a tremendous amount
of stress uh with grace in class and i
would say this is going to come off
weird but the way i am able to enjoy
touring when
it's an absolutely miserable experience
because i'm able to not victimize myself
and when i'm at these venues when i'm
tired when i'm
annoyed when i'm like sleeping in some
freaking futon and i can then we got in
later and i'm still able to be present
and gracious with the people that work
there
and i would say most venues i go to
they're like you are the nicest person
we have ever and i'm always like
you shouldn't get points for being nice
and gracious but they're like you are so
lovely and i'm always proud of that
because i'm like i have every excuse to
lose my grace right now and be a brat
yeah and i'm not gonna take it
i'm gonna try that on this first leg was
a complete and total personality change
it's that was um really tough i became a
cunt i'm a capability
because you're in a different city and
then and then and also especially in
this last year when some people have
masks and some people don't and i have
to wear a mask in this city and not this
city and there's like where's my can you
put on your math ma'am and i'm like
and then people aren't coming to shows
because there's a vax mandate and then
i'm having it like
the
when i can go through a day without
complaining i am proud of myself because
oh my gosh i should try that i mean i'll
do it for like for a living and for fun
but if yeah yeah yeah
whatever that's fine but yeah yeah if i
can just comport myself under a
tremendous amount of stress when i have
every right to complain and then choose
not to because i'm like i'm gonna invest
in my future self because i'm gonna be
coming back to these venues again and
again
yeah i don't think i'm investing in my
reputation because well i think it's
more like as a female comedian people
are so ready to call you a content bitch
anyway well i'm that's the first thing i
asked to the staff especially backstage
is like who's been here this is a total
cunt
my favorite thing i do that with drivers
i do that with everybody yeah um but i
never want uh to leave even a venue or
or if i'm able to be really gracious and
patient at the meet and greets
afterwards oh that i'm always like a
hundred percent i can't ever i can't
fuck with that yeah but i mean but
during the pandemic it was like a whole
it was a little bit it's weird weird
yeah yeah you do a meet and greet i do
it from the stage and i don't charge for
it ah oh my god that's very great i just
do it from the stage and i sort of bend
over and no one knows how to use their
phone
i bend over
um and i just like do it from the stage
okay so it's like a little
a little after show kiki yes if i'm able
to just like do that without being like
guys can you
if i don't lose my grace okay that's
those are the times yeah yeah cool you
know is that a corny answer no no i mean
that's great i have to like i have to
remember that because and i'm also proud
that i did not
get married
uh
when i thought i had i didn't succumb to
the pressure to get married and have
kids before i was ready yeah i don't
know about anybody in the room but i
hope i don't offend i think marriage is
totally stupid but that's just me i'm
gay so like i they get for gabe oh sorry
i should have told you wait what yeah
i think gay i don't gay marriage ugh you
know whatever like i mean equal yes
whatever okay fine fine but um but
married yeah
i'm with you on that the thing that i
that i try to have the caveat for is
someone i mean i made a tv show about
my based on myself i'm sorry no it's
okay and the whole thing was about me
not wanting to get married and you know
half of all marriages end in divorce
like if a
if half of all planes crashed would you
ever get on a plane would you ever fly
of course not right i would but
i
and so um
there are some people who uh that are
older that if you if you if you and i
are together just in love living
together right and you go to the
emergency room i can't go back and see
you well let's get let's change that
well like why do we need to get married
i mean that's crazy it's more that or
like some people that need to get on
someone else's health insurance it's
like it's that kind of stuff doesn't
have that there's a deeper conversation
there though like let's skip the
marriage part and get everybody free
healthcare well yes that's what i mean
like there's no larger fish to fry
we get distracted by little like i think
i'm married i'm gonna get divorced i
wouldn't i want to be a part of the
system yes it's like well
i know a couple of very famous
celebrities who are married but they
never signed anything and they had the
ring they had the party they had cool
fine nothing is signed yeah their assets
aren't like entangled but there won't be
anything yet
no i'm just obsessed i mean i just went
to the most glamorous gorgeous wonderful
incredible wedding i don't even care
about weddings but it was like i'm a
picture perfect this um my friend
marcela and it was um
it was just like breathtaking wonderful
and i am
but i'm i'm i'm so curious about um
we're fascinated by
when everybody gets married there's like
this is the one forever
and they believe it and they know it and
it's the truth
that's fine but but it's you know what i
mean but here's what i'll say
about that and i'm as someone that's on
your side oh i mean i'm not like you
know i think most people don't get as
much
attention as we do and a wedding day oh
you know what that's right that's what
interesting it's like a lot of us a lot
of people don't have
i mean we get people looking at us all
that we get photographed all the time we
get to go to movie premieres you have a
tv
show you have someone does your hair and
your makeup and all your friends are in
dresses and whereas we're the opposite
we're like i remember when i was engaged
with someone who were like playing
trying to plan a wedding i was like i
cannot do this i do this literally for a
living it's like it's like running a
show it's like i have to get the venue i
have to get the flowers and i was like
we'll go to cvs then the boot barn
afterwards i'm like i'm a showrunner i
know how much this venue normally costs
when i shoot a tv show here this is
nominal this is how much flowers should
cost like i was like this is such a
fucking racket and the idea of sitting
in here the idea of sitting in hair and
makeup without someone paying me for it
i was like ah so i also think it might
be that
like the racket you just get to have
this like you need to be the center of
attention about yeah i guess so
you get to be a dear for the day and a
lot of a lot of um regular folks like
straight people don't really have
major milestone events after that no
think about it like you have your prom
sadie hawkins bat mitzvah unless you
have kids oh then then of course i
always forget because i'm so
self-centered that
uh the natural life other people exist
yeah no they do it's like you do this
thing and then you mature and then you
pass it on and nurture another life
another thing just baby me
all day long
till the end you know like i'm never
going to have kids
like um in overboard if you have a baby
you can't be the baby
so so i think it's a little bit of that
yeah it seems so stressful to me the
idea of planning a wedding in all of the
regular oh my god who's invited who's
not who's going to be mad at me
and it's so nobody wants to go it
overwhelms me but i think when i see
some of my family members and stuff
the pressure they put on me i'm like oh
you need this they do yeah this is for
you your special day yes exactly so i
think that like the ritual of it i think
that and the emptier life gets the more
apocalyptic it gets i feel like the more
we um hold on to rituals like that and
uh
we i don't so vacations vacations when
i'm on them at really short planning
vacations yeah my favorite thing in the
world i'll plan three a day i'm planning
then i won't go on it the planning is
fun you're free i don't want to write
the chat i'm not paying for it you can
say i like planning it i like i think
most humans that don't have a day-to-day
just for terror management theory 101
having something to look forward to
people plan their weddings for two years
three years this one yeah all day every
day
i mean it's like yeah
it's something to look forward to in a
world where
we're just sinking and dying yeah i
guess that's true something like that
germs are varianting and yeah
yeah oh also half the people i know are
fully micro dosing mushrooms during the
day oh yeah
yeah acid too
what of it
is that is that fine i don't know you
should try it i'm good no no i i don't
know i have done it yeah and it did i
didn't feel like i didn't you know no no
i had uh mushroom i had acid when i was
11 at ocean city maryland and for three
days i um dug up my skin and thought i
had spiders on me i mean it can be very
intense but micro dosing is nothing like
that it's like the different it's like
it's like an antidepressant they people
do it for depression yeah different
reasons i don't know i think the real
sadness is that like
these psychedelic drugs which are near
not nearly as like um
studied or something yeah the fact that
they're not studied that they were all
outlawed in um the 60s and 70s whatever
it prevented them from getting
researched because they're not yeah it's
not like meth cocaine um heroin all
these opiates tremendously destructive
dangerous to the body super super
addictive um psychedelics are not on
that same level and they do have um i
think they i mean
they should be able to be you know i
know people that has changed their life
people that were antidepressants that
fucked them up and their dick didn't
work and they were going bald and they
couldn't feel anything they couldn't
have orgasms and then they started on
i want to say lion's mane or some kind
of micro dosing mushroom pills change
their life also placebo effect is an
effect sure sure even if it's that fine
use that medicine you know yeah i mean i
was like i
i think that the 5-meo experience was
just it was like
a huge
um
honestly it was like a life changer but
it kind of was you know like just i've
had like these mega like moments where
i'm like oh my god you just wild
revelations mostly not on drugs but just
from like you know growing up and going
through shit but don't you think that it
also has to do with your mindset going
into it for sure you have to be ready to
receive it you have to be prepared to
change because it does feel i mean at
the worst like i would like um you know
when you're literally going a roller
coaster it's too scary you close your
eyes and wait for it to be done
have you ever done that
um you just made me think of that scene
in fear where mark wahlberg fingers um
on a fair grace witherspoon finger on a
ferris wheel yeah finger on a ferris
wheel that's your next special
um what is the okay sorry when you're on
a roller coaster you close your eyes
yeah like it's too you it's too much you
can't handle it yes uh i'm scared yes
like that is what
it feels like because you're not you die
you're dead
dead i mean all of your consciousness
you're dead like that three seconds
three or four seconds but then you're
back yeah and then you're back you feel
lovely
it's almost like a trick all right
because maybe i'll do that for
thanksgiving it's so frightening and
apparently you know there's no um
there's no like really bad side effects
you don't have a hangover mm-hmm
an hour later you're like totally fine
mm-hmm like nothing ever happened but
like you and i fine or like no like i
mean you're back to normal if not a
little bit better okay yeah i want to do
that give me the
find a lab who produces it because it's
you know so illegal give me that uh aol
address of whoever practices
give me that sbc global uh email give me
the blackberry pin of whoever does this
find anybody on the street yeah yeah i
was going to say
yeah let me know which three gates to go
down here by the way yeah three gates
which are easy to walk clear around yeah
fake gates emotional gates and emotional
walls yeah well thank you for having me
in your
fucking giant compound what a dream
what a privilege when does the new book
come out it comes out on october 29th
okay for halloween just in time for help
and um we also have a tour that's going
on yes all around the world we're going
to
uh we're doing another u.s leg yeah it's
like if you go to trixie and catch it
dad.com yeah and you can um purchase
tickets on the on the internet on that
and they'll come right back
yeah it all happens and there's also so
many other things that you should know
about and i'll tell you about it and
it's all on your socials and if you guys
don't know where it is like oh and if i
don't reach a million followers on
twitter today i will kill myself oh no
pressure how
um
well i guess they'll just have to follow
oh how about i kill myself yeah um
uh
i guess i have to draw myself in your
pool
i can't let that happen it's not having
people over tonight okay suicide yeah
actually that's kind of art will you
just make sure you're face down how else
am i gonna draw myself okay yeah that's
true okay
the wig will just
um i love you we end these very
awkwardly okay
i love you whitney i see you and i
respect you i hear you and i want to
attune to you i love you guys don't
write elephants thank you bye
[Music]
one four four
[Music]
[Applause]
you